to make sure we have that coach usually
it's the year after to come back here a
catastrophic injury like the one that
Gordon suffered have you been in
communication with him and when do you
expect to make yeah he stayed in Boston
so he's been in there all summer he'll
go on the weekends he works five days a
week in the mornings see him almost
every day you know don't we
the only chance you get it not seeing it
was if you get to work late he goes
really early why so he's put in good
work and he's a he's a really good
player who's hungry to have a good
season and he's definitely putting in
the work to do that the beauty was even
through all the struggles a year ago to
me was a guy he wanted to play with
because he seemed to want to do the
right thing with the ball just taco fall
I mean he's such an interesting young
man he seems of great character and
personality the league has trended
smaller but you guys are giving him a
good look is there a place in the league
whether it's with you or not does he
have enough source every time